foreign
hey everybody what's going on it's
Monday it seems weird it doesn't seem
like Monday because we didn't stream
yesterday because I was yeah away all
day yeah so I didn't get home until like
10 or 10 30 last night matter of fact
but I had a good time she was down there
with Disney
well Disney Springs which is I you know
I can't afford to go in the damn parks
but you know walking around Disney
Springs is free
unless you want to buy something which
case you know got to pay for that yeah
Jenny with Jen was uh visiting her
brother and sister yeah my Well my two
brothers and my sister and my
sister-in-law yeah it was really fun we
had all day and wandering around getting
booze looking at stuff you know uh but
yeah so it's Monday and that means we're
talking about haunting now Danny had
given us some recommendations
um earlier about episodes that he wanted
us to do and this is one that we hadn't
done before which is a haunting in
Ireland he also wanted us to do
Spellbound which we will probably get to
next week unless somebody has a better
idea this one this is another one that I
know we must have seen it like a bunch
of times but when we were watching it
um I didn't remember it but it's
actually like a really good episode I
don't know why I keep forgetting like
all of these and I think like for a time
like you were kind of confused you
thought we'd done it already but I think
you were confusing it with like uh the
chief horror yeah the Irish girl in it
yeah because the Ouija yeah the Ouija
horror that takes place in England
somewhere but um yeah but yeah but there
was an Irish character in it but this
one uh was in a house and this took
place entirely in Ireland yeah I think
I'd only seen this one a couple times
because it was uh I didn't really
remember it yeah I didn't either I think
I kept skipping it because I kept
confusing it with the week she thinking
it was wheatshave and you're like oh
it's like that was a pub or something
yeah yeah so uh
looking at this one again I'm
just glad that it was recommended
because
um this is a good case this is classic
Poltergeist
and it ends a lot like a classic
Poltergeist ant with an exorcism which
it sounds [ __ ] crazy but I'll tell
you guys the end I mean
most exorcisms if you actually look at
the legitimate cases like the ones that
The Exorcist was based on
it wasn't a hot it wasn't a demonic
possession really it was
Poltergeist
Poltergeist uh often mimics demonic
possession because it just does whatever
you expect it to do and if you expect it
to be a demon that's what it'd be that's
what it acts like that
they were even in the case that I was in
there was
if it had it happened way back in the
Middle Ages or something or somebody
suggested that it was a demon
and that I was possessed it probably
would have started manifesting itself as
that
because it's it's a prayer it's pranking
you know
it's it's acting up it's LARPing
foreign
and like you said because it usually
comes from a focused individual yeah
then
um then how it responds uh is kind of
how that focused individual is going to
respond it's kind of like a feedback
loop you'd use yeah it's uh
recurrent spontaneous psychokinesis
under control of the subconscious
just like a character in one of your
dreams it seems totally independent it
does you're fighting it you're dreaming
it that's that's what's controlling the
Poltergeist it's just another part of
you doing it
it's weird but a lot of people don't
realize that there are other facets to
their personalities in their mind that
they can't control
you think that you're just one person
you're actually a multitude of them
and they're talking to each other
has been proven I'm well aware of that
there's a conversation going on in there
and it's like a consensus
it's got to go through it's got to go
through a [ __ ] committee yeah it's
happening and the recesses of your mind
and then it says okay this is what we're
going to do and then it's passed into
the Consciousness and you think it's
your idea but it was all their ideas
did they make an Anna they made an
animated movie about that one time
didn't they like with all the little
like characters that were living inside
somebody's head that were out of like
different emotions and stuff and they
all had to like were arguing all the
time I got a bunch of them in there
yeah it's like the one with Jack
Torrance yeah that's that's the main one
that's the main one then there's one of
them in there like Venom you know which
is kind of the same thing kind of the
same thing you know I made you what you
are that kind of stuff you know inside
out that's right that's what it was
called that animated movie yeah I knew
there was one like that I just couldn't
remember the name of it yeah it's like
Venom it hates you but it can't live
without you that kind of deal
that's messed up well it's just this has
been this has been known for a long time
I mean it goes back to that uh Star Trek
episode where Kirk had the transporter
accident he got divided into the two one
of them was a good version of him
another one was an evil version of him
and they couldn't survive alone they
couldn't survive and then like McCoy is
like this is a this is a great time to
you know to to
this is a great time to study the the
resistance of the human mind this isn't
you know he's gone on and out of stocks
going like over years you know he likes
Paco yeah
fascinating but I think we need to get
these guys together they had to put it
back in the transport in the transporter
yeah
squish them back together put it back
together yeah like play yeah
and then the skinny puppy album mined
the Perpetual intercourse is talking
about that too just you know we kind of
Our Generation grew up in a good time
when you know
with parapsychology actually was having
an impact on some of the like
underground [ __ ] media that we were
listening to and watching you know
[ __ ] it was classic Star Trek and
Goth music and it would all kind of
sometimes talk about these issues
even black metal
kind of talk about it although
I don't think they knew what they were
talking about but that's what they're
talking about
whatever as long as it's okay cool yeah
[Laughter]
yeah
[ __ ] Conrad oh what's his name
Kronos from [ __ ] Venom
I forgot what his name Conrad um
oh [ __ ] I forgot what his real name was
we just called him Chronos
we invented black metal like a zombies
you called him that you but you buddies
with him oh yeah yeah we could no he
would call him he had a stage name a
Kronos
because you were the way you said it you
were just kind of like yeah all all of
us dudes hung out together we call it we
all called him crow well we did hung up
we had the record album and yeah we hung
out with the record albums saying that
[ __ ] [ __ ] sit in the [ __ ] sit in
our rooms and [ __ ] for the past we eat
around
oh yeah man the devil
yeah that's some pretty deep [ __ ] some
deep [ __ ] man
that war with Satan man there's a
[ __ ] war in heaven
[Laughter]
the funny man all that satanic metal and
[ __ ] it was just Christianity was
indispensable it was just it was
essentially Christian none of that [ __ ]
could exist unless you took Christianity
as
the truth you know
never really got into any of that stuff
like I said it just seems it all seems
very try hard to me it's like they're
trying trying to be like oh I'm so evil
and yeah well [ __ ] he Conrad was said
in his interviews that people would go I
don't believe in any of this this is
like a horror movie it's like you know
you watch the Evil Dead you know it's
just this is all it is yeah because they
uh I think some people kind of took it
seriously yeah they took it seriously
yeah yeah it was just a big production
Big Show you know
to make you think that this was [ __ ]
real you know Conrad Lance lant that's
right thank you very much TV triggers I
wouldn't have known that Conrad land
yeah he's a good dude good dude coked
out most of the time but women liked him
well weren't they all yeah
yeah he got big too [ __ ] taking
Deanna ball he looked like a big old
[ __ ] Stay Puft Marshmallow Man
eventually retaining all that water
yeah
but they didn't wear any hardly any damn
clothes
back in their early 80s they just wore
leather straps and guitars so they had
to look jacked or these people laugh at
him
Venom was a good bad man way ahead of
its time never got any play in the
United States until later
you know
good man well what you getting kind of
like Motorhead
yeah okay I don't know if I ever I mean
I what what is she back there [ __ ]
with Spock is like Spock yes box moving
I didn't see him
this box kind of good he had something
to say I guess yeah I hope pokey's
behind there otherwise we got [ __ ]
ghosts in here yeah
maybe she's behind it I can't tell where
she went but I just saw like spot going
like that it's usually like Pokey Robin
on it but I don't I don't see her yeah
uh let's see um so do you want to get
into the case or do you want to learn
all right just go talk about the case
because you because you seem kind of
tired and I am tired and I'm kind of I
mean I got [ __ ] Sleepless and I'm kind
of tired yeah I got [ __ ] sleep last
night because I mean I got home like I
said I got home at 10 or 10 30 but for
some reason I couldn't fall asleep right
away and then I kept waking up because I
had to go to the bathroom this is gonna
be an exciting episode yeah yeah like I
said I really really did like this
episode and it's like it amazes me that
I didn't remember it because a lot of
stuff happens in this like and it's and
like you said it's it's not just like oh
we saw apparitions or stuff it was like
[ __ ] moving around yes you know what I
mean like Poltergeist yeah they'd see a
vase just hang in there hanging there
and it didn't flew off which hell yeah
Jenny's seen it hey yeah thank you very
much sending us money thank you next
Dimension media really enjoyed the
Sakura UFO episode last week thank you
very much Tom having some ins inside
info on that case made it even more
interesting with the UFO stories yeah
thank you very much yeah we should
probably do more of those I mean I kind
of feel like we've covered most of the
real iconic ones yeah but I'm sure
there's probably something that we have
well the only thing I had to add is you
know a new uh Lonnie Zamora's son was my
squad leader in Korea Sergeant Zamora I
went and checked my yearbook to see if
he was if he was in the platoon during
the time that they shot the yearbook and
he had already he had already rotated
back to the U.S so he wasn't in it
Roberta showed you showed them to you
I'll uh go through some of my friends
from the platoon and see if if anybody's
got any pictures of Zamora
because we got a lot of pictures
during that time and uh we're we're all
gagged up on you know [ __ ] Facebook
groups that are for our unit and for our
time and I'll put the word out ask if
anybody's got any pictures of Sergeant
Zamora and I'll show you what Lonnie
Zamora's son was like and I believe his
name was Lonnie too but I wasn't on a
first name basis with your [ __ ] squad
leader it's Sergeant Sergeant Zamora
that was it yeah and I had to go through
a damn redneck [ __ ] team leader to
talk to him if I wanted to talk to
[ __ ] sergeants more I had to speak to
him in smoke signals that's that's what
this team leader told me he wasn't
allowed to talk to him but you know I
talked to him anyway
[Laughter]
I wasn't allowed to go over his my team
Leader's head you know this [ __ ] [ __ ]
the 506 was [ __ ] wired tight anyway
the inside scoop was is the
I remember Sergeant Zamora saying what
the symbol on the side was
and uh that FBI agent told him that not
to not to
tell the press that symbol they gave him
another one
to give it it's it's a it was a range
finding signal a range finding
symbol to help a telescopic lands thing
to [ __ ]
hook up onto it and figure out how far
away it was and with that you could
figure out how how far away it was
moving it's like stadia lines like in
the inside of a rifle scope is like that
somebody commented on there and said
that um and described the kind of the
symbol that it was but I couldn't think
of I can't remember like what it said
though I just remember in general this
was a long time ago but I remember it
was he said it was like stadia lines
inside of a rifle scope okay it was kind
of like that but he said it was like a h
or an iron cross a cross with tops with
like bars on the side and then then
there were other ones
little ones tick marks and but it was
something that lined up with a reticle
inside of a [ __ ] telescopic lens so
if you can look at it those little bars
and lines would all line up and you
could get an estimate how far away it
was it was something like that
okay
I believe you yeah that was the story I
heard yeah
yeah I've heard a couple different
stories too but
what were the other stories well no I'm
just we already talked about that on the
show okay like you know that was that
was a few days ago I didn't know if it
was already passed okay no I would have
mentioned it on there if I knew it uh
all right so let's talk about I've heard
it was a NASA symbol too one time I
don't believe it was no I haven't heard
that but like I've heard other things
but yeah I've already said about it on
the show yeah all right so this episode
right here is from season three and it's
actually episode five
and so the story is centering around the
Fahey family in Galway obviously in
Ireland uh which is actually on the west
coast of Ireland I guess
now they've lived in this house at least
like the older couple have for they said
at the point that this um you know story
took place which was like in the
mid-1990s that they had lived in this
house for more than 30 years I'm
assuming it was like a council house
because like on here they said
government subsidized which like I said
that usually means like a council house
you just pay rent to the council and
whatever and you have to get on a
waiting list to get in there and all
that other kind of stuff
so uh the dad like the patriarch of the
family his name is Jackie and he's a bus
driver like for special needs children
and then his wife Esther um works at a
child care center she's like a cook or
something so in the house also I don't
know how big the house was but they also
had their daughter Martha and then
um Jackie's son Michael and also
Michael's uh fiance whose name was Anne
now what ended up happening was that
Martha had um just had a baby so uh the
baby's name was Sarah Louise and she was
born in 1996. so obviously the baby was
going to be living in this house with
Martha as well
um Michael and Anne were actually in the
process of like planning their wedding
about this time and he said that um
because Michael was on like the real guy
was actually on the show too and he had
just started his own business so they
were like oh you know everything looked
like it was looking up like we looked
like in a bright free future and
everything like that and
um I will note that prior to the baby
being born
they had never had anything unusual
happen in this house at all apparently
in the entire time that they lived here
and like I said that at that point had
been more than 30 years
so which like I said leads me to believe
more that like you said it's kind of
more Poltergeist thing if I mean if it
happened the way they said I think it
was probably yeah because you know
spoiler alert they actually did kind of
go like oh it's a haunting and there's
like a story about it but it sounded a
lot more like Poltergeist yeah they
always do that they try to make some
story behind him yeah well you know I
have my own Theory
go ahead okay well yeah we'll get it
okay
so now like not too long after the baby
was born I believe when the baby was
about eight months old the neighbors
started doing like renovation next door
so it's like their Council houses
they're connected you know what I mean
um you know so there's on the other side
of the wall so there's like a bunch of
noise going on in the Next Room so they
actually had to move the crib like the
baby's crib over to the other side of
the room because like there was kept
like banging on the wall like over the
crib or whatever because they were
renovating over there
so not too long after I guess the
construction started because it wasn't
real clear because they were saying oh
the baby was born but from what I looked
up on other sources I think the baby was
eight months old like when the neighbors
started doing the construction and they
said a few months after the construction
or a few days after the construction
started Michael
he notices like this horrible horrible
smell he said it smelled like rotten
meat like in the house
now the first thing he thought like most
people would he's like oh maybe like a
rat died under floorboards or maybe the
pipes are backed up or something like
that so Jackie the dad he comes into the
house and smells it too he's like Jesus
Christ what the [ __ ] is that noise what
the [ __ ] is that smell you know what I
mean now they can't figure out where
it's coming from like they're going all
around the house and it's like it seems
like it's coming from here but it's like
then they go over there and it's like
and then now it seems like it's coming
from over there they said it seemed like
the source was like moving around and
they couldn't figure out exactly where
it was coming from
so they called the landlord up to
complain about it
and the landlord sends a couple of guys
out the next morning to have a look and
see if they can figure out what this is
weirdly though the guys come in and they
don't smell anything at all like there's
like we don't smell anything like
describe to us what it smells like
because we don't smell anything it
smells totally fine in here
um and but at this point like Jackie and
Michael like I can't believe you can't
smell that because it's like it's so
overpowering that we can't even like be
in here it's like we can't even take it
any longer what's that telling me what's
what that is telling me is that that
Aroma is not there yeah the sensation of
that stink is being put directly into
the mines
of those people which is be more
efficient for Poltergeist to do that
than to generate molecules that had a
stake you know yeah it's the illusion of
it
um but so here's the weird thing is this
has happened before in other other kind
of cases it's happened to me
I thought there was a gas leak in the
house one time and I could smell [ __ ]
propane or I could smell it nobody else
could
but it's just my imagination yeah there
was no gas leak
yeah because that's the thing it's like
your sense of smell is a sense just like
any other one so if your like eyes can
be fooled and your ears can be fooled
like your nose can too I had convinced
myself that there was a gas leak because
there was a propane bottle in there and
I thought it was left open or I thought
that not the left though I thought it
was leaking right
um the connection you know I thought the
connection I was convinced that the
connection wasn't right it kept
bothering me kept worrying me and I
could smell them I could smell it
but um no there was no leak
well you know how sometimes too like if
you smell something bad and then like
even after the smell is gone like you'll
still keep smelling it yeah and I think
after her time it's probably like that's
just gotta be like sometimes poker guys
cases will start
with weird phenomenon
begging okay
Phantom smells
but are you are you is it the
Poltergeist that is causing these
or is this phenomena causing the
Poltergeist in other words your
imagination of this weird smell the fear
of it is starting to ramp it up
you hear banging on the walls next door
where you and where the uh where where
uh
construction is going on and it and
that's bothering you
and you're worrying about that you're
worrying about that waking up the baby
in this case
so stress starts to be introduced into
the environment yeah which might cause
the Poltergeist
it might cause it because I think it's
the mama in this case
that's doing it she just had a child
eight months ago who knows what her
hormones were like and then the stress
in the house maybe Financial stress
and we don't know what's going through
her mind
maybe a part of her didn't didn't you
know wasn't happy with the
family situation and this is some kind
of form of psychic Rebellion
to maybe help bring the family together
tighter against the common foe or
something
maybe she felt insecure there like you
know like they were going to get
divorced or something or they were
getting kicked out of the house maybe
so
having the threat of this
demon or ghost all right is what is
holding the family together now so she
feels safer in a way
in the in the face of a threat
so she generates it using a psychic
abilities at a subconscious level that's
what a parapsychologist would say I
would agree
based on yeah it is kind of interesting
that nothing weird had ever happened in
this house this whole entire time
because this family had been living here
the whole entire time yeah it's not a
ghost and nothing weird had been
happening but like because of the you
know one-two punch of the renovations
next door and the baby being born like
over just like a brief period and like
you said there might have been other
stuff too like on the show that they
didn't mention right Financial stress or
relationship problems right it could
have been lots of stuff right because
they didn't really specify like Martha
who was the baby's ma the baby's mom
they didn't specify like where the dad
was you know what I mean like he didn't
live there with them okay because you
know what I mean because Michael and
Anne were the other two yeah you know
what I mean they they were the ones
getting married it wasn't their kids
that's right that was Michael was like a
single mom yeah like Michael was
Martha's brother there you go right
there so it might have said there might
have been something I don't I mean I
don't know I don't know them but I'm
just saying I just speculated there's
some kind of stress for the from that
and
um woman's hormones you know go kind of
crazy during the whole birth process and
the child rearing process and then she's
under all this stress that should be
enough and I don't know how old she was
but age really isn't a factor
puberty is a factor but I've I've been
able to reproduce it
here here in my [ __ ] 50s
it takes longer and it's not as
impressive and it doesn't last as long
usually if it's a teenager or a young
person it's not all it's not going to
last longer than a month
and then it go it gets resolved
one way or the other eventually and how
this was resolved is I think is how a
lot of them are resolved a person's
talked out of it
but okay let's go
yeah so uh so yeah so these two guys
come over to like check out the smell
and they don't smell anything and just
you know to humor the people
in the house they go up and they pull
the toilet aside it's like they check
all the pipes inside and outside and
stuff but they're kind of um Jackie the
dad he was on like the real guy was on
there and he said yeah they were just
looking at us like we were imagining it
or we were nuts or something like that
and they were like yeah I don't think
it's your pipes that's the problem or
something like that it's like but we'll
check anyway like while we're here but
they didn't really think like anything
was wrong
now over the next few days like after
those the guys left and they couldn't
find anything uh the smell they say got
exponentially worse like Esther kept
cleaning like all the time and dumping
bleach all over everything like down in
the drains and stuff like that but the
stink just kept persisting
um to the point where they just all felt
like they were constantly nauseated like
they couldn't get away from it and
nobody else could smell it but them I
mean apparently like the the two people
that came like to look at the [ __ ] they
couldn't smell it
now they said that a few weeks later the
smell suddenly just vanished with no
explanation like just as suddenly as it
had started
and not too long after that Michael and
Anne are sleeping one night and then are
awakened by the sound of a baby crying
now of course the first thing they think
because there is a baby in the house as
they think that it's Sarah Louise and
they're laying there woken up and I'm
like why doesn't Martha like get up you
know get up and pick the baby up and
like try to quiet her down or whatever
um and they're like that's that's really
lame since baby's just crying and crying
so Michael's like all right [ __ ] this
[ __ ] so he gets up and goes to check on
the baby but when he goes in the nursery
Sarah Louise is just laying there very
quietly like with a pacifier in her
mouth it wasn't her that was crying even
though he can very very clearly still
hear hear a baby crying like really loud
um but it's obviously not her because
he's looking right at her and she's not
crying yeah and I think it would travel
around the house too huh the sound yeah
they kind of heard it everywhere
they kind of heard it everywhere because
that seemed like a very common thing
this baby crying yeah so Michael comes
back in the room and Anne's like oh um
you know what was the deal and he's like
yeah that wasn't uh the baby that wasn't
the real baby crying it's like I don't
know what the [ __ ] it is and he said as
soon as he came back in the bedroom he
felt like someone was pushing on his
chest like he couldn't breathe
so you know this is Ireland I guess I'm
presuming they're Irish Catholics so he
grabs a rosary and kind of starts
praying and like the feeling goes away
but then he said that him and Anne both
started praying but the more they were
praying like the louder that the baby
crying got like they said it almost
sounded like they were hurting it you
know I mean like when they were praying
it just kept getting louder and louder
so then they they stopped praying and
then the crying also stopped like very
very suddenly which they thought was
really weird
so some unspecified time later it might
I think it was the next morning actually
so Michael goes into the kitchen and
Jackie and Esther his mom and dad are
just searching frantically through the
kitchen like looking for the baby's
bottles they're just like they were
right here in the cabinet and now
they're gone and they can't find them
anywhere
um so they're like where did you guys
move them did you either like no like we
haven't touched them I don't know where
they went now Michael said did you guys
hear a baby crying the night before and
they're like no I don't know what you're
talking about so the mom and dad didn't
hear it
um Jackie said at this point Michael was
starting to get he called him like
getting withdrawn and Michael says look
I think this house is haunted like I
think something's going on and he's like
I heard all this baby crying and it
wasn't the actual baby and maybe that's
what happened with the bottles too like
maybe the ghost moved it move them
um but Jackie's like you have got to be
[ __ ] kidding me I was like and he
just like laughs it off and Esther the
mom she doesn't really believe it either
and she's like you know just stop
talking about that kind of stuff it's
like that's not what it is
so at this point too is like Michael
gets very frustrated and he just yells
hey if there's a ghost in here like give
us a sign
but nothing happens at which point like
his dad is just kind of like
see I told you like there's nothing here
so you just bend down the pub too much
drinking he said
so later that night I think
it was that same night
um Michael and Anne go to bed and again
they hear this really loud baby crying
and so they're just like sitting there
on the bed and they just keep praying
and praying at this point like Jackie
comes and like knocks on their bedroom
door and is like hey can you guys put a
[ __ ] sock in it because he's like I
still want to hear a baby crying but all
I hear is you [ __ ] in here
praying and you guys are getting louder
and louder and you're keeping us awake
so knock it off uh you know he's getting
a little pissed off about it
now a week after that
Jackie the dad and Martha
they take the baby to like you know just
a doctor's appointment or whatever
and they come home
and when they go into the nursery to put
the baby in her crib
they find a bunch of the babies stuffed
animals arranged in a circle facing
outward like in the middle of the floor
and then in the middle is like an open
music box which is you know playing its
Little tune or whatever with like a
little ballerina in it now this reminded
me very much if you remember the other
episode of Haunting which called Sally's
house pretty much the same exact thing
happened in that like in the nursery
where they came in and like all the
stuffed animals were like in a circle
inexplicably yeah polish do that a lot
the one that we had would uh arrange
things on the floor and patterns or in
some way or another uh it arranged
little hand towels on the bed one time
in the in the shape of a smiley face
two eyes a nose and a I got a picture of
it
yeah
so that's the pictures in the book and
yeah I think it is yeah even though that
that wasn't that Mammoth that was at
Lois's house
later
it's weird
made a little face
and it didn't take long to make it
either
that is pretty weird yeah but I just
thought it was really strange the way
that particular thing with the stuffed
animals was like exactly like the
Sally's house thing which you know was a
completely different case because I
think that Sally's house I think that
happened in the US I think we did a show
about that but it was a long time ago
so Jackie sees this and he's like um
well it must have been just like Michael
or Anne like playing a prank but
Martha's like yeah but they're both at
work so and like why would they do that
anyway you know what I mean like nobody
was there so there was really nobody
there to do it
so one night again some unspecified time
later Michael and Anne are sleeping in
the room as usual and they get awakened
by what Michael described as like a
bright orb
and it looked like at least from the
reenactment that it looked like it came
in through the window and then it kind
of he said it kind of like slowly
dissipated like it was this really
bright light like came through there and
then they started hearing the Phantom
baby crying again
now he tells his dad Jackie about it the
next morning but Jackie's like oh it was
probably just you know a car headlights
like a car coming by like shining in the
window but Michael's like look you know
we have cars coming by here all the time
I know what [ __ ] headlights look like
and he's like and this was way way
brighter than headlights
and Jackie at this point is like art
he's like tell me right now to my face
that you did not do the weird thing with
the stuffed animals and Michael's like I
swear to God he's like you know I
wouldn't do that he's like I didn't
touch them and at this point like
Jackie's like okay he concedes that
there's probably something paranormal
going on
so he's like well maybe we should call a
priest
now Michael's like I don't think a
priest would believe us and we probably
couldn't get them here anyway so
Jackie's like well why don't we put a
tape recorder in the baby's room and see
if we can record the weird sounds like
the baby crying and maybe that would
serve as proof and then maybe the priest
will come there like if we play him that
you know what I mean so Michael says
okay it's worth a shot so he's gonna put
a tape recorder in the baby's room like
that evening
so Michael goes up there to put the tape
recorder in the nursery but then he
realized he's like oh [ __ ] I left the
blank tapes downstairs because this is
the mid 90s you know what I mean
um so he goes downstairs to get them
and while everybody is downstairs they
hear a really loud noise coming from the
nursery and then when they go back up to
check
they find the tape recorder is totally
busted like into a bunch of pieces like
in the middle of the floor they said it
looked like somebody threw it like with
great force you know what I mean in the
reenactment it looked like it was just
kind of like all together but it was
just like incomplete and total pieces
like it wouldn't have done that if it
had just like fallen off the dresser or
something it looked like somebody had
like slammed it like down on the floor
like it was all broken into a million
pieces
so um meanwhile while that's going while
they're checking upstairs and being like
how the hell could that be all broken
apart like that Esther and Ann are
downstairs and the curtains on the front
window start like opening and closing
like really fast like in quick
succession like yeah a few times which I
think happened in your thing too didn't
it yeah I just turned away from the
curtains or walking away from them
towards red when he was in the dam
doorway and boom or no actually it was
him he he was turning away from I was
watching I was looking at him and he was
walking towards me and uh behind him the
curtains [ __ ] flew open it was and it
was like a gunshot he nearly ran over me
and uh to get away from him and he
turned around and looked at him because
God damn they flew up and said yeah
and it was like
in a single stroke I don't think he
could have pulled them that hard because
you know there was like you know those
little it had a little rope that you
pulled to open them yeah
I think if You Yank that rope
fast enough and hard enough to do that I
think that road would have broke
you know what I mean I don't know how it
was done it was done by just pushing
them open at the front the top I think
it was weird and um
I remember like one of the curtains that
the way it moved looked weird you know
like the bottom of it snaked up and oh
man it was weird really weird make a
jump out of your skin you know and back
it
hair on the back of your neck and
[ __ ] stand straight up like a cat you
know like
yeah it's weird man
yeah that was like the first thing I
thought like in this one I'm not like I
said I'm not sure because in the
reenactment I don't know if it's exactly
like what they saw but in the thing they
showed them like opening and closing
like really quick like a couple of times
like two or three times like
[ __ ] like that and the you know the two
women were just like nope and then
Jackie came down and it's like they
looked [ __ ] terrified and he's like
all right we're getting the [ __ ] out of
the house like right now yeah just
thinking about that thing flying open
back then man it's got my hair standing
up on the back of my neck right holy
[ __ ] what if that did yeah that's right
yeah yeah don't say that don't say that
Jenny
yeah that would be really something so
so yeah so Jackie tells everyone to get
the [ __ ] out of the house well like I
said these I these these Irish people
they don't [ __ ] around it's like as soon
as like some haunted [ __ ] starts
happening they're like yep we're out bye
they don't like hang around do you know
what I mean so they get the [ __ ] out of
the house so they go over and stay next
door with their neighbors who are like
really good friends of theirs
and so they basically all just camped
out on their neighbor's floor you know
what I mean like just little sleeping
bags or whatever and Jackie said okay
well I'm gonna call the church first
thing in the morning and see if there's
anything they can do about it
so a few days after that uh the parish
priest comes and he's gonna bless the
house
now during the blessing
the Phantom baby starts crying again
and they all said it seemed pretty clear
that the priest heard it but pretended
that he didn't they said you could kind
of tell like from his face that he could
hear it and like his voice was getting
louder and [ __ ] like that but it's like
he was pretending that he didn't hear it
because I guess he was like freaked out
no they told him to ignore it
well that's what yeah because I think
they went into that on like one of the
other programs where they're just like
supposed to pretend that it's not
pretend that it's not happening right
yeah because that's like oh you're
giving it power like if you give it
attention kind of thing yeah I can't
remember what episode that was but an
episode we were talking about before I
think they specifically were talking
about that yeah the priest said don't
get don't pay attention to it it'll go
away yeah because the family were like
well easy for easy for you to say
because you don't [ __ ] live here you
know what I mean but yeah so he's like
pretending that it's not existing but
they said you could tell by his face
that he could hear it though so they're
like and the baby crying was just
getting louder and louder and all of
them could hear it like all the family
could hear is you it this is definitely
Poltergeist phenomenon
and one of the weird things that I
noticed and noticed it throughout a lot
of the case is that the cases that sound
legitimate to me because they kind of
follow the same kind of pattern that I
saw happen with with uh with our [ __ ]
incident of mammoth
and Beyond
um
in general Poltergeist don't talk they
don't speak
they can vocalize but they don't
and they can write but maybe only a word
or two and it's scribble you know so
whatever's doing this in the human mind
using these psychic abilities
because not a part of the brain with it
has verbal skills it understands speech
but it can't reproduce it but it can it
can reproduce the human voice it did on
one occasion I talked about it in the
book but it just sounded like a bunch of
garbled backwards stuff and I ran from
it it was just coming out of the thin
air
[ __ ] in the corner of a dark Road man
I was trying to sleep in it's at Lewis's
house this was after Mammoth that would
follow a week
it was [ __ ] spooky it sounded like uh
water bubbling at first and that kind of
went backwards or what started sound
like backward masking on a down record
you know rubber up like that you know it
was [ __ ] bad yeah I I would not like
that if I just heard that coming from a
random corner
and then it
it had been throwing [ __ ] clothes on
me
I wasn't hiding from it underneath the
dam
sleeping bag and I could hear the
[ __ ] drawer open up from the dresser
Rusty's dresser and some and then a
t-shirt hit the top of the [ __ ]
sleeping bag and then drag its way down
to the foot that was another night
though they did that that was [ __ ]
pissing me scaring the [ __ ] out of me
[ __ ] with me
yeah yeah
and it was you know it was just like
that you saw that remote jump jump off
the [ __ ] table
imagine if that was close coming out of
a dresser drawer in the middle of the
night hitting you on hitting you on the
head and you're hiding underneath the
Blake I was like you [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah you can't go anywhere [ __ ]
pitching socks at me and stuff yeah come
across the room yeah and when I woke up
the next morning all the Rusty's dresser
drawers were open and it was all empty
and all of his [ __ ] laundry clean
laundry was piled up at the foot of my
uh sleeping bag
have anything better to do than just
like pitch clothes that you all know
yeah I guess not I fell asleep I didn't
fall asleep I passed out I think from
Fright I just [ __ ] he just shut down
shut down because it was throwing
clothes on me
but um so
but it they can't speak
if you start hearing these stories of
them of it speaking
um I would immediately think it was a
[ __ ] falsehood
they didn't
they didn't like it didn't like to be
questioned because it couldn't really
answer it could make shapes it could
draw little things make little smiley
faces
it could scribble a word or two it could
understand what you were saying but it
would get frustrated if you tried to
make it right just throw the pin at you
it they don't have ver it doesn't have
verbal skills whatever
part of the brain has this ability
you can't speak
it tries but it just it can't it's not
it's not it doesn't have any verbal
skills
which I think is important
so it's one of the one of the
hemispheres of the brain
so that's a that's I think that's a hint
or a hint a clue as to what it is
we were trying to analyze it you figured
out what what it was
you know
Lego gets a ghost well what kind of a
ghost who is it you know what does it
want
you know is it a ghost is it just an
invisible being maybe isn't it an
invisible beat being like From Another
Dimension there's a lot you know
red came up with a lot of good
explanations of what what it might have
been he's like this could be an alien
it's just invisible in another dimension
but you know no it was too humanoid
too human-like you know what would an
alien be doing that for
we never know they're an alien it was
that it was doing stuff across doing
what a child would do and a monkey
but enraging things in [ __ ] geometric
patterns why would why would a human do
that
you know why would a ghost do that
weird and it would do it fast
with seconds you know turn your back and
turn around there'd be a geometric
pattern or something that you would just
been touching you know
and things from other rooms in other
parts of the house and you don't know
how they even got in that room so they
must have [ __ ] teleported or
something
because you didn't see them pass you
it's wild man it's a real wild [ __ ]
phenomenon
Zach says uh one to ten how bad are the
Irish accents in this episode
not bad actually I I think a couple of
the actors might actually have been
Irish I'm not entirely sure they're not
as bad as the wheat Chief accents that's
for sure I mean those were pretty those
were pretty wretched these ones were
passable I think they were Irish
I think some of them were I think some I
don't think all of them were but um but
it was certainly like a lot closer than
like I said the wheat sheep one which
were obviously not British people
you know what I mean I had an Irish
girlfriend when I was living in Boston
her name was Fiona Fiona O'Shea and
[ __ ] I used to try to do that accent
and she goes no no she'd get mad no I
would get mad too if you were right let
me see if I can do it and I try to do it
she goes ah no it sounds like [ __ ] you
know excuse me
well she was probably right though so I
was just trying to do it yeah I couldn't
do it though
yeah actually I think I was eventually
starting to get close to it but she
didn't want to she didn't want to give
it to me you know she's like no
right I just it's I very very rarely
heard an American that did like a a
really good British accent like I'm sure
there are some
that can do it but
I'm just going mostly by like actors and
stuff like that it's like you can always
tell I'm not really sure but it's not
true the other way around because I've
seen lots of British actors that I
didn't know were British actors and they
were playing Americans and it never
occurred to me that they weren't
Americans yeah so they can do it a lot
better the other way around and I don't
know why that is dude from The Walking
Dead he sounded he's he sounded Andrew
Lincoln yeah
although I didn't even realize until
later because I hadn't seen I didn't see
Love Actually which was like a British
movie that he was in before The Walking
Dead I hadn't seen that so I didn't
realize that he was a British actor yeah
until much later yeah he sounded
Southern uh now later on sometimes he
slightly overdid it uh with the southern
isms uh the draw a little too long
sometimes but it was close I mean that
was within parameters
you know if I get around a bunch of
[ __ ] rednecks man we're drinking I my
my accent gets much stronger
just a few minutes of talking with my
dad I'll like go back in time
to like the 1930s [ __ ] you know
Isabella said Bridget Jones the accent
is excellent that okay that's an
exception yeah because that actually
what the [ __ ] is that what the [ __ ] is
that actor's name that American actress
um [ __ ] yeah she played Bridget Jones he
was a British character and I thought
she did a good job like on the accent
but that's like the only one I can think
of though I'm sure there's more about
that but yeah so thanks for bringing
that up but the thing about it is that
Andrew Lincoln was also on an episode of
um that new like Guillermo del Toro show
Cabinet of Curiosities and he played in
American on that one too although he
wasn't playing a southerner he's playing
I think he was from
Boston or he was more like a New England
but he did that fine too he was fine
Renee Zellweger thank you yes because
the British can act they actually train
him
American actors they're not they're
they're not they're in there I mean some
of them are some of them have been
trained over here but it's not like I
said it's not we've kind of gone into
that before it's kind of not like a
story I don't think it's taken as
seriously that's not serious here you
get you get a partner play but you know
how well you give head or whatever it is
on the [ __ ] casting couch or how many
how much how many drugs you're gonna
[ __ ] uh contribute at the party and
just you know it's that kind of [ __ ]
your Crooks
yeah
there's no act there's no acting craft
the best actors we had that was like a
generation ago
and they weren't that great they were
just better than what was available in
in in in Hollywood you know
Robert De Niro and [ __ ] and they had
narrow
bands
if I can Dustin Hoffman
he's all right it's just he wasn't that
great you know he wasn't you know that
great he was just he was good
mego says Love Actually is worth a look
I've seen it since then I don't love it
it's very very chick flicky and that's
not really my thing but um and it's a
little bit weird I think I'd be really
weirded out like if Andrew like if
somebody pulled like what Andrew Lincoln
does to that poor girl in this movie
like showing up like on the eve of her
wedding like with the signs like saying
he's in love with her and stuff I'd be
like
yeah I don't think that's so great
a lot of stuff in here I don't think
it's like so great Zach says Meryl
Streep has left the chat
ah
Danny Rowling said Glenn Quinn from
Roseanne was irish-born and was good at
masking his accent
even in the 97 Anthology film campfire
Tales yeah it's like I've had it happen
like a bunch of times where I saw a
movie like or a TV series and it didn't
even occur to me that any of the actors
on there were not Americans if they were
playing Americans and then later on like
I saw an interview or I found out they
were British or something like that I'm
like oh well good on you because
you fooled me and I've lived here pretty
much my whole entire life so you know
Mega said oh yeah he's a stalker boy he
yeah he is he's a stalker
I mean you know I don't think we should
encourage that kind of behavior so what
are you talking about I'm just saying
it's a movie called Love Actually it's
like it's like a British Christmas movie
um but yeah so
there's a really funny article I read
like a long time ago about how where
it's just like eviscerates like Love
Actually and it's like [ __ ] hilarious
um so yeah so where was I all right so
they all get in the house they go to the
neighbor's house all right so the priest
is there
the baby crying gets louder and louder
the priest is just like ignoring it la
la you know and he's just like keeps
doing the blessing and everything
they're like okay well now we gotta go
bless the upstairs so he goes into or
they try to go into the baby's room into
the nursery but when they get up there
and try to open the door to the nursery
the crib is apparently up against the
door from the inside which also happened
in your case not with a crib but it was
with a bed right like a bunk bed a bed
now um it almost tried to do that with a
dresser one time but you could get it
open
um
it's just the dresser had moved it
looked like it moved it towards where it
tried like it tried to do it you know
but it it didn't the the dresser didn't
make it all the way
but I like the the fact that the
neighbors are starting to become aware
of it they're getting involved the case
because that happened
that happened in Mammoth Mountain it's
uh when we got the Lois's house Lois
told all her friends who were neighbors
she knew them well enough to tell them
and um so when it pit when it kicked off
it lowers that Lois's house this is a
week after the the main event
um they got to see some of it they got
to see it so yeah other people witnessed
it too you know one of them was uh
Red's friend
of Jimmy and Jimmy saw that knife action
thing happened
and he goes okay man I gotta go man this
is too much and he left and they never
saw him again yeah he noped right out of
there and
red had known him for a couple years
they never saw it do it again he was nah
man I'm nah man
yeah man that was weird yeah man I I
can't handle that man that's everything
he worked a [ __ ] Round Table Pizza
interesting he was a cookie walk
Roundtable Pizza go down there get some
free pizza
I don't know see I always thought that
would be like really really fat I know
it's scary and stuff but I always
thought it'd be like really fascinating
I don't see I don't think that that
would make me be like yeah no I'm not
gonna talk to those people ever again in
the early 80s man when people didn't
have a there's no internet and people
really I guess you didn't have much
contacts no contacts were right and you
you know people like we can't tell
anybody they'll think we're [ __ ]
crazy yeah but you could tell close
friends and relatives and they'd come
over they could see it
yeah
yeah this whole idea why don't you call
the cops man [ __ ] the cops you weren't
going to call the cops they'd come they
just [ __ ] arrest you you're crazy you
know send your ass to a [ __ ] mental
Asylum yeah I feel like we did I mean
unless you can see a [ __ ] Intruder in
your house I'm not calling the cops
they're not dealing with that situation
shoot you that's what I'm saying
yeah that's that's how that would go
they take the kids from you'll be all
too crazy to have children we got to
take your children that's what I do
don't move bam bam bam bam yeah it
wouldn't go well for you it wouldn't go
well for you yeah just saying it's like
the death squad yeah that's California
man well I'm just saying like it'd
probably be [ __ ] well yeah like well
and it's probably gotten worse since
then yeah to be honest with you like
everywhere I wouldn't call the cops
unless I was like in a [ __ ] dire
peril
and if you call the newspaper they would
immediately write up something about how
crazy you were and they'd call [ __ ] a
Child Protective Services you should
well I mean we'll get into that because
the media did get involved in this one
but it's like in in a way like I think
the media getting involved it was kind
of like shitty at first but it did end
up like helping them in the end yeah so
they didn't really know what else to do
like I said this wasn't
this was pretty like not
pre-pre-internet but pre-like internet
being widespread this was like mid 90s
so all right I mean we had the internet
in 95 but it was still pretty
rudimentary yeah you were the [ __ ] if
you were on the internet 95 yeah yeah we
had just got it and like I said it was
like super shitty like it's you know it
was dial up a lot of stuff on Hot Topic
across the internet [ __ ] 98. I
thought I was the [ __ ] man
all of a sudden [ __ ] futuristic man
yeah internet purchases
well yeah it's like now everybody's just
like yeah big deal yeah big deal no man
back in 98 that was some [ __ ]
high-tech [ __ ]
so yeah so the priest goes up there they
can't open the door I mean they can't
open the door but they kind of open it
part way and he's like oh the crib is
against the door from the inside and
then the priest kind of makes a crack
like oh well you guys did that and then
Michael's like how the [ __ ] could we
have done that how could we get out like
there's not another door or nothing
so um but they were able to kind of like
you know the crib's not heavy so they
were able to like kind of pull Push the
door open and they said hey priest get
in there and like bless that [ __ ] so um
the priest goes in there and he does the
funny thing that always makes me laugh
like because they just said a lot on a
haunting were the priests will go in
there and she'd be like bless bless
bless okay bye I'm done you know what I
mean he just like runs the [ __ ] out of
there
which I thought was like very very funny
he didn't run but he was clearly just
like yep and then he left
so they're kind of like okay well we
hope that whatever the priest did like
that whole deal has made this better but
just to be on the safe side they decided
they were all gonna sleep downstairs
like in the living room like so they all
camped out in the living room so they
could all be together
in the middle of the night though Jackie
the dad is he got woke up by I guess
like a creaking sound I think he kind of
heard the baby crying too but it was
mostly like a really loud creaking noise
like somebody was like walking down the
steps or like um of the upstairs
upstairs hallway or something
so he goes up to see like what's going
on
and on the landing there's like a vase
like on a little side table there and he
said it suddenly just floated up in the
air pretty much he's like just right in
front of his face like that he said it
tipped over and then just fell to the
ground and like broke
and he wigged the [ __ ] out yeah he said
I mean he ran out the house and fell
down the front stairs and he said he
didn't even remember running out the
house he just remembered like coming too
and he was like laying on the lawn
because it like freaked him out so much
seeing that [ __ ] bass do that like
right in front of his face that's what
he said so he didn't even like remember
running out the house
so they all go over to the neighbor's
house again I mean these neighbors are
Saints man like putting up with this
[ __ ] all the time like all these people
like running over here every five hours
ago like holy [ __ ] our house is haunted
so you go over to the neighbor's house
again
um but they're like okay well we can't
keep imposing on the neighbors we have
to find some other place to stay so they
have a relative who I think they said
was Jackie's sister but she lives like
four hours away but she has like extra
room she has like a big house so they're
they're like considering going there
because Esther the mom she's like I have
to get the hell out of this house I need
some rest I'm losing it
um you know she's just really not doing
well
so Jackie and Michael go back to into
the house to like pack some stuff for
her and Jackie so Jackie and Esther are
the older mom and dad they're gonna go
to the relative's house but Michael and
Martha and the baby have to stay behind
because Michael and Anne have to work
and you know what I mean
they can't just like take off and like
go four hours away
and Martha is like well I'm gonna stay
because you know even if the house is
haunted it's like the ghost hasn't
really done anything to her or the baby
now Martha is the person that you think
is the focus of this right because
that's the baby mama
but she made the point that's why she
didn't leave because she said
it hasn't done anything to harm me or
the baby because that's one thing the
baby didn't really seem to be aware of
anything that was going on and didn't
really seem to be adversely affected
which was good but you know what I mean
all the people all the adults were
though
so Jackie and Esther said well they felt
really bad about leaving everybody there
but Esther just couldn't stand being in
the house anymore and she just had to
get the [ __ ] out of here so the next day
Michael and Ann have to go to work so
they leave Martha and the baby alone in
the house
now Martha hears the baby crying
upstairs and goes up to check on her but
the door to the nursery won't open
so she runs to the neighbor's house
again for help one of the Neighbors
comes over with like a toolbox and they
try to pry the door open and like but as
soon as she gets in there like with the
Crowbar or whatever the hell it just
goes and like opens by itself right
um and Sarah Louise the baby is just
like laying and they're like what you
know what I mean like nothing at all is
going on so Martha just like Scoops up
the baby and is like nope and goes out
into and stays with the neighbors all
day again
so then when Michael and Ann get home
from work they find a note from Martha
saying uh yeah some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
happened and I'm over at the neighbor's
house so Michael goes over to Thatcher
to bring her back home and leaves Anne
alone in the house so Ann is like
sitting in the living room looking very
nervous then starts to hear that
creaking sound again it sounds like
somebody is walking on the stairs or
like walking on the upstairs hallway
like it's really really loud and then
she starts hearing the baby crying again
then a picture of Sarah Louise that's
like framed on an end table she said it
flew off by itself and like broke all
over like the glass broke all over the
floor so Anna's like yep nope and runs
out of the house and she tells the other
two what happened because they're like
out in the yard
so like we gotta go so they all climb in
Michael's car uh Michael goes back in
the house like to get the baby carrier
and some diapers and [ __ ] like that now
while he's in the house he said oh well
I better call Mom and Dad and tell him
what's going on and tell him where we're
gonna be because we're not gonna stay in
this [ __ ] house now and he said when
he was dialing and trying to call like
there was a weird noise on the phone
it's very Amityville Horror it was like
a very weird noise on the phone almost
like he said it was almost like they
didn't like it was the ghost or whatever
like didn't want him to call
so he tries to call again
and then he puts the receiver to his ear
and there's this really horrible like
high-pitched sound and then he said and
this is going a little bit I don't know
I don't know if I buy this or not but he
said he dropped the receiver and he said
it like melted like it was melted in the
middle like what they showed on the
reenactment it didn't look like it was
you know melted like a puddle or
anything like that but it looked like
the middle part it was one of those you
know receivers where you kind of bit
this bent like that but it was like just
kind of like melty in the middle yeah
um and then he said he's just like yeah
no and he runs out the house he said he
felt like someone was pushing him out of
the house and then he goes out on the
porch and then the front door just
slammed like they were like yeah get the
[ __ ] out you know I mean the melty
receiver is plausible
um there's a related phenomena sometimes
happens in Poltergeist uh uh cases uh
called uh
pyrokinesis all right which is where
spontaneous fires happen which would be
easy for rspk to do that you're just
accelerating the molecules to they get
hotter and then it would burst into
flames so if you can move a big object
you can move little objects no problems
like some objects the size of molecules
heat is just motion
so
all you do is agitate in the molecules
in that plastic receiver and it gets
soft
you know that's all that's all it is
yeah I guess so be easy be easy for
Poltergeist to do it although I never
seen it do it but it was never suggested
had I asked it to do it it probably
would have
yeah because it did do stuff that you
thought about yeah it responded to to
requests
yeah he's got a nice that last time I
told her to do something I asked to give
me give me some money and it did
remember gave me the coins from gave me
the coins that were sitting on the side
of the bed yeah
you know just moved him to where I was
never taking any money from the bank
that we'll see that's what we wanted
it's like well this was already my money
so yeah
[ __ ] I'm trying to get me somebody
else's money okay some like a whole
bunch of money that they won't miss yeah
they just gave me a stack of [ __ ]
nickels and dimes
that's it just put that out there into
the universe it's like maybe one of
these days you'll wake up and there'll
be a big stack of cash
like at the end of the bed yes from the
bank yeah on marked notes on a big old
[ __ ] square see just talk about it
the more you talk about it the more
likely it is that it might happen it'll
stack of hundreds yeah we could really
use that right now
a meter Square that's how big on a
pallet sitting right there Pam
manifest manifest that [ __ ] just
teleport it yeah just think about it and
think about it visualize well probably
there'd be another person inside my mind
going no we can't do that because that's
cheating and oh shut up other person
shut up other person tell that other
person to shut up did you just lay
around do steroids and [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're gonna have to get out so yeah you
know but there's always somebody in
there who's going to try to mediate
everything like I said tell that person
to shut up they don't know what the [ __ ]
they're talking about give me a whole
[ __ ] stack of [ __ ] hundreds
from a secret I would submit you know
just to that to that one person in your
head that when you don't have money it's
much easier to just lay around in bed
because like well I don't have any money
to go anywhere yeah you know what I mean
like I can't go out to eat I can't go
out to the club I can't go out drinking
or anything like that because it's like
I don't have any money so you're just
gonna stay around in the house if you
have money you're just like let's go out
and do this that and the other thing I
mean at least that's what I'm like
yeah so I'm just saying so tell that
person to shut up
visualize I'm visualizing it
I'm visualizing it so so um so yeah so
the family entire family now like stays
away because I guess Michael and them
they went and stayed somewhere else too
so the whole family has stayed away from
the house for a few days but then like
after a while they're like well we have
to go back because like we have to work
and stuff
um and you know Esther and Jackie they
kind of want to move like Esther is kind
of bummed out because she's like man
she's lived in this house for like 30
odd years she's like I love this house
um and now I just don't want to be here
anymore because of like all this
horrible [ __ ] that's going on but
because it's a council house
um you know they have a long waiting
list like to put you into a new one so
they said you know that's maybe like a
five-year wait or something like that
like to put you in a new house so
they're like there's no way we'd be able
to like move right away
so they go into the house and in the few
days that they've been gone uh it looks
like it's been completely trashed like
it looked like a tornado hit it like
Michael said it looked like it had been
a ransacked like people have been in
there ransacking it but nothing was
missing like they couldn't find anything
missing like [ __ ] was just broken and
just thrown everywhere paper everywhere
[ __ ] like that
so at this point like I said it's the
mid 90s so Michael doesn't really know
what to do he's like well maybe we
should go to the media and then if
somebody hears the story then maybe
somebody will help us because they
didn't you know no internet you can just
like go search Ghost Hunters of Galway
or whatever now Jackie says I don't
think we should do that because you know
people will just laugh at us
but Michael's like well you know I don't
know what else to do like we have to
like fight this thing this is our house
you know what I mean
so the family ends up doing a radio
interview
with um a radio station in Dublin and it
kind of got a lot of play so
subsequently they have there's a
newspaper reporter gets sent to their
house to do a piece on them
now they said that this when this woman
showed up
um they said it was pretty clear that
she didn't believe them and she even
said like straight up like look I don't
believe in ghosts or I don't believe any
of this paranormal [ __ ] now she was
supposed to stay in the house overnight
I think but she starts writing the story
like almost as soon as she gets there
and they're like well why are you
working on the story already like you
haven't even stayed here and she's like
well I don't think anything's gonna
happen so blah blah I thought I'd get a
head start on it or something
so Jackie and Michael at this point they
just kind of look at each other because
they're like well they know something's
gonna happen because they just noticed
that the house got really really cold
and they said that's how you always knew
that something was going to happen
because the house always got really cold
like right before
so the reporter like comes in the
kitchen with her laptop and she's like
hey can I come in here work on the story
they're like sure yeah whatever so while
everyone is in the kitchen like they
hear something really loud like breaking
in the living room so they all run out
there to check and there's like this
porcelain uh figurine or something like
that and it's broken in a million pieces
like in the middle of the floor like
somebody threw it like I said with great
force
um they said the reporter was very
clearly scared shitless
but she's like well don't touch the
broken thing because I got to take a
picture of it because this is like I
need a picture for the story
so the story comes out in the paper and
it you know it went the 1990s equivalent
of viral I guess they said it's
reporters started coming from like all
over Europe it was in all the papers
um they started calling the thing the
Galway ghost so now there's like
reporters and media and [ __ ] like that
like all over their lawn like you know
shoving microphones in their faces and
people started whispering about them
whenever they went anywhere hey it's
those crazy people that said so some of
the [ __ ] that they said was gonna happen
like that ended up happening although
the reenactment it wasn't too bad they
basically just showed like one or two
reporters on their lawn and them going
like we didn't ask for this and like
slamming the door but it didn't look
like you know what I mean there were
like people camping out of the [ __ ] or
anything like that
now several days after that I guess the
initial reporter that did the newspaper
story
she actually calls them and she said um
there's this woman and her name is
Sandra
um ramdani I guess that's how you
pronounce her last name and she's A
parapsychologist and A Healer she says
she had degrees in Psychology and
metaphysics that's what they said on the
show now she has her own Wikipedia page
too but I mean there's not a huge amount
on it but I went and checked it out so
you know uh so she comes to the house
and the family said yeah you know as
soon as she came in like you could tell
she was like a really nice person like
she very warm presence they said but
Jackie was like really skeptical he's
like I don't really believe in any
psychics or anything like that so it's
like we were really kind of like okay
let's see what you can do then
so um as I said now Sandra has her own
Wikipedia page she's still alive
um she actually and I think this is kind
of interesting and I don't think this is
um not anything we really argue about
but she thinks that psychic abilities
are
an innate part of the human
consciousness and that they are not
Supernatural Powers which okay I that's
I'd agree with that
um
also she said she first discovered her
abilities after entering a haunted house
in Trinidad that's where she was born
actually
um on a night out drinking which okay
um
and also she said that she had she first
realized she had like extraordinary
abilities when she was two years old she
said she could answer complicated
medical questions posed to her by uh
medical students like when she was very
very young and she said that her psychic
abilities also helped her complete
College because she knew what all the
answers to the on the tests were going
to be
uh she's also published a book in 1995
and it's called trapped between two
worlds experience of a Ghostbuster and
in 1997 she apparently claimed a 50 000
pound reward for exercising a ghost I
guess from uh some Manor Hotel like um
in County Kerry the ghost was like
supposedly groping female guests while
they were sleeping and I guess they paid
her all this money to come in and do it
and I guess it was successful
because they paid her the money but
that's a lot of money so I don't really
know that's what according to the
Wikipedia page anyway
but so yeah so she does have a short
Wikipedia entry
so back at the Fahey house
um the one we're talking about Sandra
said she was worried about Esther in
particular because she looked like
really tired and drained like she
couldn't really take this [ __ ] anymore
and she also said that she was glad that
the baby Sarah Louise didn't look to be
adversely affected by what was going on
now the family pretty much tells Sandra
everything
and she's immediately interested in the
fact that the phenomena started not long
after Sarah Louise was born
so she goes up to the nursery and kind
of starts feeling the walls and like
doing the whole I'm feeling The Vibes
kind of thing
and then she asks them apparently before
they told her anything she's like have
you guys done any construction in here
and Jackie says no but then Michael said
well you remember the neighbors did some
and they had you know we had to move the
crib to the other side of the room
because they kept banging on the walls
and [ __ ] like that so Sandra was like oh
very very interesting uh Jackie said
that he was very freaked out that she
knew that like without them having to
tell her you know what I mean so she
asks if she can be left alone in the
nursery
so she can meditate or whatever
so while she's in there she apparently
said she started smelling something that
smelled kind of like smoke for a second
and then she sees a really Vivid I guess
it was like a vision
and she said that she saw the room
around her but it was like a completely
different room and she sees this young
girl who's having a baby
and this man who she said was apparently
her dad she said she got the sense that
it was her dad is helping with the birth
and then there's another man presumably
the baby's father like kind of standing
off to the side and looking kind of
angry
so the baby is born and then the girl
starts like reaching for the baby and
screaming or whatever and then the
girl's dad hands the baby off to the
other guy who just straight up Smothers
the baby now the dude that smothered the
baby was a [ __ ] dead ringer for
Michael Shannon for a second I was like
is that Michael Shannon it looks just
like Michael Shannon I mean if you guys
have seen this episode is it just me I
thought that looked just like Michael
Shannon he's in a new movie about George
Jones and Tammy Wynette by the way
which actually looks really good I love
my machine but yeah so the guy looked
just like him
so Sandra's story that she apparently
gleaned from her vision
is that sometime in the past not in this
house I think I think she said that it
was just on this land or on a house that
was on this you know spot of land Lake
previously
she said the baby that you hear crying
is a phantom baby obviously fancy baby
um and this baby is essentially haunting
the place after having been killed
because it was born out of wedlock
so she says that the baby wants to be
mothered by Martha you know the living
baby Sarah Louise's uh mom
and is essentially engaged in a little
bit of like sibling rivalry with Sarah
Louise because the ghost baby wants all
the attention because you know how ghost
babies are yeah they have to have all
the attention at all times and they
don't want no living babies getting in
the way so that's why I like that baby
was like really cranky and throwing [ __ ]
around and everything Korea was filled
with baby ghosts
yeah yeah that's a big thing in like
Asian folklore baby ghosts because they
were throwing their babies up on the
mountains to die
there's like a whole I mean if any of
you guys have seen like um Yokai
monsters like any of those weird ass
movies from this for the 80s or 70s I
can't remember 70s
um but there is a baby girl maybe yeah
maybe late 60s but there's a baby ghost
in there that has like a big giant head
yeah that's like my favorite Yokai from
that I mean they're all good the
umbrella is good too but I like the baby
ghost he's cute yeah they didn't really
have abortion so they just gave birth to
the baby threw the baby away
and that's what the that's what the baby
goes was all about Abandoned children
hello they just starve speaking of
babies
leave them out to the elements
and I guess that was here's the thing
though some people said it happened
during famine times other people said
that it maybe didn't happen that it was
more modern Koreans and Japanese people
believing that that was a a common
practice in in ancient times for them so
we're worried about the ghosts of all
those children
so it may not have happened yeah yeah
you know what I'm talking about yeah
they might have just been in the legend
yeah
um all right so where was I oh I all I
will also note that I found a very brief
article about this case which was on
um it's called RTE which is Ireland's
national public service media
and they mentioned that the death of the
baby apparently that this woman saw had
happened they specified that it happened
a century before so 1890s and was also
witnessed by a priest and a nun which
they did not mention on the show but I
don't know if that's true or not but I'm
just saying that that was in the article
but it wasn't on the show on the show it
was just like the girl's dad and the
baby's dad and the baby's dad like
smothered the baby because apparently it
was born out of weather I don't put much
in because of the shame
I don't put much in well yeah I don't
really see any like I mean is they
didn't say that there was any way to
like back that up no you know what I
mean you can say whatever [ __ ] you
want maybe she had a vision maybe she
just made the story up
to tell to the people there to justify
an exorcism that would get rid of it
you know what I mean yeah the exorcism
did get rid of it yeah I mean they
didn't call it an exorcism she called it
a healing yeah the same thing the
exorcism system did get rid of it
because people believed the story and
believed that it would get rid of it so
it got rid of it yeah I think it was
that Mama
you know and it was good and she must
have known it was Poltergeist it was
only going to last a month or so anyway
yeah yeah because that stuff is usually
very right so she comes she cooks up a
story oh it's not you it's this uh baby
ghost baby ghost got killed it's okay
hey you know we're gonna get rid of the
baby ghost okay baby goes gone you don't
have to worry about it and then the the
phenomenon stops because she believes it
that's what I think happened I mean I
kind of let I know I know this is
terrible I'm a terrible person
um but Sandra she says okay we're gonna
do a healing ceremony to release the
ghost baby like the spirit so she is
like well we don't want the real living
baby in the house just in case like [ __ ]
starts flying around or whatever so
Jackie and Esther are the the older like
grandparents they take the baby out for
a walk or whatever and they're like okay
well all the rest of us are gonna do
this healing ceremony so Sandra lights
like some candles and puts some crystals
and [ __ ] like all around the nursery
like they do
and then they bring in a bassinet and
they put it in the middle of the room
and so then they all like join hands
like close their eyes do all that
Kumbaya kind of stuff like around this
bassinet and then she asked them to
imagine that the ghost baby is
manifesting inside the bassinet yeah and
to send all their energy like toward the
baby like to release the spirit so the
ghost baby this I don't know why this
made me laugh but so the ghost baby like
appears in the bassinet like in this
Golden Light like
this is like golden baby the scent of
sanctity I know it was it was that kind
of situation and then the baby starts
like floating up towards the seat I was
like oh my God anti-gravity baby and I
was because I'm a terrible person like I
said but I don't know [ __ ] like that is
just very very funny to me I'm like
floating baby like you can't get much
funnier than that I'm sorry yeah a
little ritual would give people the
faith that they needed to think that the
ghost baby was gone and that's what
ended the damn Poltergeist phenomena
that's what I think happened but yeah so
this baby starts yeah feeling and then
it's like they do like a brew like
across the ceiling or whatever now
Michael said the real Michael who was on
here because most of the family members
were on here so Michael was on here and
his parents were on here and like the um
the Sandra lady she was on here
now Michael said that he saw the baby
going up into this white light but
although the program showed him actually
seeing it like with his eyeballs
I kind of feel like it's more like he
just saw it in his Mind's Eye type like
he was like imagining it but I think it
was like they showed it like more
impressive because he was clearly like
wow like looking up at it like with his
eyes open rather than like his eyes
closed like imagining it imagined it
yeah that's kind of visualize it they're
visualizing right the thing going away
which helps to dispel the phenomenon
yeah okay that's how I think she did
yeah basically Witch Doctor suggestion
yeah I mean yeah I definitely think
that's that's the case here so they said
that they immediately like all felt
better like oh the ceremony worked so
they go downstairs and then they said a
couple minutes later like Jackie and
Esther came back into the house like
with Sarah Louise and they said as soon
as they came in they said it worked
didn't it like they immediately knew
like the feeling in the house was
different or something like that
um they said oh everyone was laughing it
felt all warm and [ __ ] like that so
um you know they said they're all like
happy and I guess they lived there for
but I don't know if they still live
there nowadays because like I said that
was a long time ago and this show was a
long time ago but apparently the ghost
baby went off to wherever it goes
because
yeah they're in New Zealand the
weather's good there
only rich people live there so yeah you
know what's you know what's weird you
should say New Zealand because I just a
movie that um that I just watched this
morning while I was on my exercise bike
that I'm gonna review this week was
actually a New Zealand horror movie oh
yeah okay man it was really good it was
intense I didn't know like one if it was
like a thriller you know what I mean and
it was like I had a hard time watching
it it was like [ __ ] it was like
really really suspenseful I was like oh
[ __ ] this is like so bad but yeah
baby on the ceiling sounds like
Trainspotting yeah oh that's right
that's right the baby crawling across
the ceiling the Trainspotting I remember
that
then Mega said that is a freaky theme
that it's like [ __ ]
but yeah so goes baby floating up to the
ceiling so I guess that was like uh that
was the end of that story golden baby
floated up to the ceiling
and everyone lived happily ever after
and as I said I don't really think
I mean I don't really think anybody like
looked this case up because I thought
the implication was I thought she
implied that it hadn't happened in this
house that it happened
on the land or in the house previous it
was funny but this is Ireland so you'd
think the how I mean 100 years old is
like there's a lot of houses there that
are that old and like way older and
people still live in there because
they're Stone you know what I mean hey
we've known about this case you could
put this in an unseen hand
yeah I didn't really I didn't find much
other than yeah it didn't really come up
yeah because yeah this this is like
because this is classic yeah Poltergeist
yeah like Phantom noises yep like
Phantom smells [ __ ] flying around
like Steph arranged yeah like in weird
patterns and [ __ ] like that yeah it
didn't last long neighbors saw it uh
feeling did they say any feelings of
presence or anything they never did no
they never mentioned that um a couple
times Michael said that he felt like
something was like pushing him or like
he or like it was like like he couldn't
breathe like pressing on his chest or
something but yeah nobody said that they
saw any apparitions or felt like someone
was there nobody said that I don't yeah
I'm pretty sure nobody said that I would
have written it down but yeah but other
than that it seems very very
poltergeisting yeah it's Poltergeist but
this was a good episode so I'm surprised
that we didn't remember it better I kept
passing it over thinking that it was
Ouija you thought it was wheat cheese
yeah I mean Wheatsheaf is a good episode
too but I tend to like ones that are in
houses more than places of business but
you know
I don't know why that is yeah all right
so we should uh probably go ahead and go
because we gotta uh watch that damn
movie don't we yeah we got to watch a
movie so we can talk about it tomorrow
we'll probably do um we're not on a lot
of sleep so that's true like I'm really
really sleepy yeah because like I said I
didn't fall asleep until late and then I
woke up a bunch of times and then I woke
up really early like usual so yeah I
mean we've been going for like almost an
hour and a half so that should be fine
all right so tomorrow we will do a
matinee show probably we're gonna watch
we're gonna find something to watch
that's like not too long because like I
said we're both really sleepy so it
might be a universal movie
because we've been talking about doing
Universal more Universal movies so we'll
try to find something that's like not
too long
so hopefully you guys can drop by
tomorrow evening and join us
thank you for hanging out with us today
we will see you guys again tomorrow
evening good night